hello my name is Roman Eric from the
Android developer relations team and
today's design byte I want to show you
how to take an existing icon and flatten
it to better match androids flatter
style for things like action bar icons
and notification icons now this is a
technique that works with raster icons
things like p.m. G's ideally you'd be
starting with vector shapes and things
like illustrator files or vector shapes
in Photoshop and working on those but in
some cases you simply don't have those
source materials and in some cases it's
actually really hard to replicate the
the icon using vector shapes so let's
take a look at how to do this in
Photoshop how to take an existing icon
and flatten it to better match that
style the first thing we're going to do
is open up an existing graphic here
we're going to just tweak the to set up
a little bit to make it a little easier
to work with and we're going to create a
new fill layer it's gonna be black and
we're gonna put it at the bottom
I guess below the primary layer now the
next step is to merge these two layers
and then go into the the curves tool and
this curves tool is going to let you
tweak the brightness values of the
pixels and your icon now these
brightness values will in the end become
the transparency or alpha values for the
final icon so we'll take our black
background and leave that as black and
we'll take this gray we'll make that the
the brightest part or the the most
opaque part of the icon we will then
select the entire icon just like the
entire layer we'll copy it into the
clipboard and we'll
a new channel now this channel is going
to be the basically the final alpha
channel for our resultant graphic and
we'll paste that graphic that we have in
the clipboard into this alpha channel
and this is the big step the key step
here is to then load this alpha channel
as a selection and that's going to be
using this this button at the bottom
right now now once we have that alpha
channel loaded into a selection we can
go back into the layers palette and
create a new layer and then simply fill
our selection with a foreground color
now this foreground color should depend
entirely on your needs if you're
creating an action bar icon or you are
using the the normal holo dark and holo
light styling then you can get the right
color and opacity values from the action
bar iconography section and the design
guide or if you're trying to use a
different color that better matches your
brand this is the point in which you can
put that in then we'll simply fill the
selection and then deselect our
selection and then get rid of the
original icon and that's it what we're
left with is basically a layer you can
turn this into a smart object to resize
it down to smaller sizes but we're left
with a layer that has a single
foreground color with no special effects
or anything like that and we can use
this as potentially a source material
for smaller icons and that's it for
today's very quick design bite on how to
use Photoshop to take an existing icon
and flatten it